hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to another code review the
series in which you guys sent me your
code and your projects and i take a look
at them if you have a cool project you'd
like me to take a look at then check the
description below there's some
instructions on how you can send it in
today we're going to be taking a look at
something a little bit different than
usual
we're going to be taking a look at
a chess clone now i'm not really sure
what like a chess clone is because like
chess is not like a video game i guess i
think this is just a chess
game because
the the original chess board game i
guess if you made a board game that
would be a chess clone right anyway i'm
not sure how many of you are fans of
chess i am a fan of chess that's why
this kind of stood out to me i don't
think anyone sent me uh chess before
okay uh i stand corrected but anyway i
guess julian really lucked out here
because we're going to be taking a look
at this today i'm a huge fan of your
seatbelt series and your code reviews
videos always helpful for me i'd like to
thank you for that
thank you i created a chess clone in
cpus with sdl2 it basically initializes
the field renders the pieces calculates
possible moves and game states and
prints out the winner at the end every
piece has got its own class derived from
a base class called peace lovely lovely
object-oriented programming it works
fine by the way
that was like half a joke and half not i
know that a lot of people like to bash
on like object oriented programming i'm
not really here to bash on this
especially because this person is likely
like a beginner let's just let's just
dial down the hatred it works fine and i
couldn't find any bugs yet but i'm
pretty sure the code is not very well
written okay cool here's a link to the
repository which we will take a look at
in a minute would be an honor if you
could review my code and tell me a bit
more about what exactly could have been
written smarter and stuff like that okay
so just general kind of advice i guess
i'm 22 years old and a statistics
student from germany who got into
programming at my university i don't
really i don't really care if my name is
displayed on i'm not really sure if the
build process works if you just climb
the river my gosh
everyone and the builds man what is it
with you people and just making code
that just builds i'm honestly
considering just making a video
dedicated to like how to build c plus
plus code how to make a repository how
to make a project and then just
build it how to distribute that how to
how to build i never learned stuff like
that and it's much self-taught knowledge
i'm already excited about your response
well luckily i am responding hello again
hello
[Music]
again
i rewatched a code review of yours and
made some mistakes previous people
also did
like not putting stl to into my
project i tried to fix that
messed up everything
i'll text again when it works like it
should
thanks sorry these code reviews are just
getting very boring hello one last time
hello one last time
after some painful hours of trying to
set up the repo i think i'm finally done
it should now be possible to just follow
the steps in my readme and have a fully
working project sorry for the spam and
thanks for being patient all right so
what we're going to do with today's
video
right is we're going to
we're going to not go over the build
process i have done this pretty much
every single
uh
code review episode almost i've gone
through and fixed the code given advice
on how to make code that is buildable
that will just work that you can just
clone set up properly how to do that
relative paths absolute parts literally
covered all of that go through the
passcode review videos if you are
interested in seeing that i'm going to
cut that out of today and we're just
going to cut exactly right now to the
code but first
this video is sponsored by skillshare
for those of you who don't know what
skillshare is skillshare is an amazing
online learning community that has
thousands of different classes on
literally every topic imaginable that is
designed to help you learn new skills as
quickly smoothly efficiently as possible
they have classes on like literally
everything if you're trying to learn
more about photography videography how
to make youtube videos illustration
productivity marketing singing
i could probably benefit from that
skillshare have got you covered with
plenty of amazing classes to choose from
and one of the things that i really like
about these classes is that they're not
like you know they're not like lengthy
they're not just stretched out they're
very much to the point they're not
optimized for youtube where like watch
time matters or anything like that they
are specifically their own platform
designed to make learning as easy as
possible for you and the cool thing is
that skillshare is offering the first
1000 people who click the link in the
description below a one month free trial
of skillshare premium you'll be able to
check out their entire library of
classes and see if there is something
there for you so definitely go ahead and
do that sign up for the one month free
trial and see if there is something
there that floats your boat huge thank
you as always skillshare for sponsoring
this video and over here as promised we
see the code does it run of course it
runs did i have to spend hours figuring
out how to run it
of course no i'm kidding it wasn't like
hours it was like maybe 10 minutes but
anyway we're here so f5 and this is the
game this is the chess clone so uh i'm
assuming white moves forward yes just
just checking just checking relax i know
how to play chess so we click okay so we
have to click and hold i guess and then
we can drag this over here
uh okay let's play with game of chess uh
what are we thinking like bomb cloud
opening probably okay so the knight
seems to move
as normal i mean i'm just going to try
and i guess evaluate the pieces i don't
even know how i should be testing this
let's see oh
can't castle okay so that's that's the
problem we definitely want to be able to
castle i'm assuming well if we do it
that way she's going to move the rook
yep can't castle also i'm noticing the
extreme kind of blurriness of the pieces
for some reason we'll check that out in
a minute as well but otherwise i guess
it's a pretty functioning game of chess
again apart from the lack of castling
i'm just gonna go ahead and try and like
check mates
let's see what's a quick little
checkmate i can do i guess what we
should probably do is yeah like let's
take a piece
okay that works
yep
yep this is pretty cool and quite
functional um what i was going to do
uh let's test the check right so here's
a check
uh can i just move the bishop no i can't
it doesn't say check or anything that's
okay i can move the king uh can i block
yes i can block maybe like move this
here
move this here for a little check
okay why doesn't check that doesn't
indeed seem to be working this has just
become like a chess video really i mean
i'm not sure what you guys expected who
needs c plus code i am entertained would
it be nice to have like some kind of
chess ai uh but i guess this will do i
guess i'll retreat from my bong cloud i
guess we should uh
no let's go ahead and be aggressive okay
fun time is running out that was
actually a mildly annoying move well
actually it doesn't matter he doesn't
have to take it
let's just say he goes here and we can
uh let's do this this and
that okay white wins there we go so it
looks like the checkmate detection works
i'm pretty satisfied to be honest the
only thing missing again is castling
would be lovely to castle i don't think
it's really possible to play a game of
chess without like having the ability to
castle so that definitely needs to be in
there but other than that you've done a
pretty good job uh i mean oh one thing
we actually didn't test out is on
poisson
but i'm sure that that probably won't
work if you can't even castle but let's
uh let's reboot this okay so for this
we're just going to advance something
and then let's try this and
oh
so you did on poisson but you did not do
castling wow okay anyway let's just dive
into the code so the first thing i'm
actually kind of uh oh
quell data
source files ah yes you mentioned you're
from germany cool
those of you don't know i went to school
in germany for a while so i know german
kind of decently but i've never kind of
interacted with computers well at least
programming wise in german so this is
kind of interesting to look at because
means like like a kind of a spring like
a spring of water that's how i've kind
of used that word before so it's
interesting seeing it as literally like
source
here we go
this is
this is what i'm talking about that that
is what i think of when i look at your
source code all right anyway so uh
mainlobe.h mainly brown i love this i
love how clean this is
let's get rid of that bright light i
love how how clean this is um it's nice
you know you have a static static
function here which again you know like
not too bad um you know when you have
something like this class main loop
static void run from what you mentioned
how like everything it looks like you
know bishop king knight all these things
are separate classes you know i can see
that you're very object oriented like
literally you're you're oriented around
object you're used to using objects but
in class possibly don't have to do that
and for something like this right again
i would recommend that maybe it would be
better to just have like a static void
main loop doesn't have to be static at
all um maybe maybe chuck that into like
a namespace called chess or whatever the
name of your program is but otherwise i
would just have something like this and
then implement it in the thing static is
really only if we want to have it like
within one translation unit which we
don't really or i mean i guess if i'm
explaining i should explain it properly
static in this context kind of means
that it's going to be local to a
particular translation unit which is
basically a cpp file so if we include
this header file in multiple files
they're basically going to have their
own version of this main loop function
or if you just include it in like a cpp
file then this will not be a global
function it will only be visible inside
that one kind of cpp file but anyway
obviously since we are just doing the
definition in the cpp file and the
declaration here we can just leave it at
that i would do something like that
instead right and then obviously this
would look something like chess main
loop right or you could even call it
chess run or whatever you're kind of
just moving the main function over there
it's not it's not a huge deal or
anything but i guess i would just
encourage you to think about like the
fact that you don't really need classes
why like why is this a problem well
again it's really not a problem
but you could do interesting things like
this right which doesn't really make
sense and i mean you can technically
write code like that as well even though
it's static so i think in general it
could be a cool exercise for you to kind
of uh try and sway a little bit from the
path of the objects anyway let's take a
look at this uh kind of main run loop
first of all i really am digging how
clean the code is like honestly like
there's no
fluff anyway it's just like main run
then we have a run function and then
here we have everything you know
sometimes i really like code like this
for simple applications like this chess
game why
because
instead of having like an init function
and then like in it this other thing i
mean we do have a handler in it over
here but like my point is instead of
having a billion functions and then it
being really hard to navigate
everything's really really clear and
that's always something we like to aim
for okay sdl handler we make a new
instance of this and then initialize it
again i have a feeling straight away
that this should not be a heap
allocation
but let's take a look at this i mean
there are quite a few things here it
doesn't really matter though okay so
public so const and screen width and
screen height 640 by 640 fixed would be
nice if it was resizable and then we
have a window we'll be rendering to
while you're even using the m underscore
if you're using like m underscore and
all that stuff i'd probably make sure
these variables are private i'm not sure
if you use them outside of this
uh
you might i guess yeah i mean use m
event here the whole kind of way that i
like to use that m underscore convention
is for basically private member
variables so if something's public i'll
usually just slap it in like that
um just so that it's kind of clear but
private members i like to prefix with
this m underscore variable again just a
personal opinion of mine uh nothing
actually physically wrong with this it's
just more of a code style window we will
be rendering to service contained by the
window renderer event like mouse etc
this is kind of nicely uh annotated
initialize the field
i'm not sure what that means i guess you
may initialize these things the fields
um returns true if everything worked
okay clean up um destructor so you know
this is one of those things where i
would probably do the init in the
constructor and then the cleanup in the
destructor because you can kind of take
advantage of
objects right this is a good good time
to take advantage of objects speaking of
taking advantage of objects one thing
you could also do because i'm sure that
you call handler clean up at the end is
you could get rid of this not call
cleanup at the end but instead just make
this a stack variable like this and
you're going to be taking advantage of r
a i i resource acquisition is
initialization which basically just
means that your constructor is going to
initialize stuff and your destructor is
going to de-initialize stuff and that's
that process is going to be automatic
because it's going to revolve around the
whole way that stacks work inside c plus
plus i think i have a video about like
stack uh
stack stuff like stop using stack scopes
scope lifetime something like that i'll
have that linked up there definitely
check that out you did mention that
you've seen the simplest series so maybe
you've already seen that video it goes
into more depth about what i'm talking
about but anyway the way that we would
set that up here is by basically
creating a constructor as well as that
destructor that we've already got what
does the destructor even do nothing
right so this is going to be perfect and
then we would just call cleanup from
here
and then call in it from well i'm kind
of did that the other the other way
around but we would call clean up from
the destructor init from the constructor
that means that again we don't need this
and we don't need the cleanup that i
already removed right and then basically
this handler arrow becomes handler dot
then we'll just replace that everywhere
in this file uh and then we're basically
good to go this game seems to take in a
pointer so we can just give it the
memory address of this let's double
check to make sure that all of that
worked but it should and it looks like
we are good to go so this is a great
example of where it's important to
not allocate memory on the heap all the
time not only because you then manually
have to delete it which by the way now
that i think about it you were never
doing right so uh you didn't have like a
delete handler at the very end right
which you need to do i'm assuming you
also haven't done that for game so these
are all kind of memory leaks they're not
really big deals in this case just
because uh you know this basically lasts
for the lifetime of your whole
application so i don't know maybe you're
like super cool and you've deliberately
not deleted that i would delete it
anyway just in case the destructor is
running certain code but also just
just to be kind of clean right so in
this case you would come over here and
then you would type in delete game
because if you've manually allocated
something with new then you have to
destroy it with delete but again you
know instead of doing that you could use
smart pointers
by just writing something like scd
unique pointer which is which kind of
uses the same concept as this it just
wraps this kind of allocation in a class
that will be automatically destroyed at
the end of the scope right because the
unique pointer itself is allocated on
the stack um and then you would just uh
do std make
unique
and then pass along
the arguments like so
right so by doing that what it means is
everything else remains the same but it
just means that the destructor gets
automatically called you don't have to
hold delete and by destructor i mean
like the unique pointer
class itself will call delete on
the um object that is inside it right so
game has a new kind of game object
inside it when this unique pointer is
destroyed when it goes out of scope it
has some code in its destructor that is
basically this
right so it will in fact call that for
you
okay moving on quit so critical is false
and that's basically while quit is false
uh i personally don't like to write code
like this usually you'll see code
written like this a lot more often right
so instead of actually doing equal
circles false or equals equals true you
just write quit again no real difference
it's just more of a stylistic thing that
most people like to do so i would
rewrite that to that
um and then what do we do sel poll event
and uh oh okay that's cool this is nice
so this game is entirely event driven
meaning this isn't like your typical
like let's render frames as quickly as
we can or at vsync meaning like 60 times
per second or whatever your monitor's
refresh rate is instead of doing all of
that this is basically entirely event
driven meaning that the game does
nothing until you like click on
something and then it re-renders the
screen so this is really cool actually
that should mean that it's extremely
like efficient however i don't think it
is the reason being that you're using
sdl poll event
in a while loop in a well this is the
big while loop in in a while loop
constantly right without sleeping or
doing anything so what this actually
means most likely if i'm not
misunderstanding this is that you
probably have like a hundred percent cpu
usage just in that loop so let's go
ahead and open up task manager and see
what it says about our chess app okay
power usage
very high right so the power usage is
very high uh cpu usage is about five
percent now i have a lot of cpus like as
in i have a lot of cores i've got 16
cores 32 threads but you can see i mean
the cpu scheduler is moving this around
uh actually let's go to let's make it
just stick to one core so if we go to
details and then just set the affinity
uh let's just clear this let's go cpu
seven okay so now it's only allowed to
run on that one core so if we go to cpu
seven which is this one over here you
can see how that is just completely
maxing out right so power usage is very
high
and we are maxing out
our cpu core that is running this we
have a thread fully occupied doing
nothing but checking for events and then
of course if i was to close this
then suddenly this core is going to be
able to relax okay so how do we fix this
well might be more simple than you think
if we change polyvent to weight event
which i happen to know is another sdl
kind of function that will actually
sleep and release the thread while it's
waiting for events and we run this again
that one little little change if we go
back here let's take a look at what this
is saying now
and check this out very low because
nothing's happening right and then if i
should still be able to move and
everything should still be fine but
again very low 0.1 percent and then if
we come over into our cpus let's just
make sure that that affinity is still
set okay let's go ahead and set it again
i mean it doesn't really matter core
seven you guys kind of get the point
then you can see that this is our core
seven it's now doing probably other
stuff because we are in fact doing
pretty much nothing and we're using like
zero percent cpu usage right so that is
a much better way to go than using 100
usage doing absolutely nothing but point
being
my my main takeaway from this is that
it's cool that you've done it in a loop
because i know that a lot of people
would just kind of implement this as a
game and again i guess there's not too
much wrong with that because it probably
wouldn't take
more than like a millisecond per frame
anyway and then it would just v-sync it
would just wait it would just kind of
sleep
but doing it kind of event driven like
this is just cool because we haven't
looked at anything like this before okay
moving on so if handler event type is
quit then we we set quit to true um i
mean it's probably not worth doing
anything else here i mean i quit quit
probably would be the last event to be
set so it's not a big deal but i would
just kind of break maybe or like i don't
know continue just in case you have some
other code or something just because it
kind of doesn't make much sense to me to
to kind of say that quit is true oh this
is this while loop yeah so i then i in
that case i would definitely break right
because although it doesn't make much
sense to me to kind of say that okay
quit it's true but then let's continue
checking like all this other stuff right
speaking of which this event type as far
as i'm aware is only uh capable of being
a single type at a time i don't think
this is like
well you're comparing it with equals
anyway so i would probably make these
else ifs
just so you're not checking each and
every single kind of case even if it's
this one or i would just use a switch
statement over like handler.m event dot
type right and then you can kind of
implement all of your case
statements um
like this with like a little break over
here and then it would look something
like this instead and you can add
scripts around them if you have any
problems with like variable names or
anything like that so i would probably
do something like this
again you know a huge deal but if you do
go with if statements because you prefer
them or whatever i would just definitely
use elsif for all of these just to make
sure that you're not rechecking event
states when you don't need to with the
point being that it can only be one type
at a time okay let's uh
add that back in moving on so handling
event type mouse button down and in that
case we uh okay so divided by 80. i'm
assuming 880 640 80 yes so 640 divided
by eight is 80 and there are eight okay
so we have an eight by eight grid i
didn't actually notice that it had zero
padding yeah it has zero padding right
so this entire game area 640 by 640 each
cell because they go from
they they fill up the entire bounds here
of the window they're 80 pixels each um
and so what we're doing here is we're
just basically converting this mouse uh
button kind of x position so where we
clicked we're just dividing it by 80 to
get the coordinate of where we are in
the world right so in other words if
this is like 200 pixels across or
whatever if we divide that by 80
we're gonna get like what like two
because it'll be like two and a half and
then we'll round down to two so two is
zero one two we know that we're in this
cell so this is simply working out the
kind of x and y coordinate in this kind
of
grid cell coordinate system right
uh and then it's called start probably
because we're able to drag it and then
that way we know where we drag it by
also doing end inside this if mouse
button up so when we release the mouse
so this will render the possible moves
um if clicked on is not null pointer
where we are right clicked on right so
then what this will do is then use these
coordinates to retrieve the piece that
is there so clicked on is now a piece
right which is like a pawn or whatever
that is what we're dragging and then if
it's not null which again you can check
just by doing that right this is also
very popular in c plus plus other
languages don't really support this but
because pointers are just numbers you
can check them as if they were like
bullying expressions so if the pointer
has a value then it's going to be true
otherwise if a pointer is null pointer
it's zero which means it's false right
so this is just a trick that we not only
a trick but it's something that we do
pretty often instead of having to write
null pointer but i totally understand if
you want to write null pointer just
because it does
make a bit more sense to some people
okay so if clicked on uh get team equals
game get turn this prevents us i assume
from moving the wrong team's pieces so
we can't have two like black moves in a
row or two white moves in a row
and then if that's both true then we
render possible moves and then this is
going to calculate all of the possible
moves and then re-render
probably like the whole board
oh no this will just sorry this is just
showing the possible moves so this will
actually um kind of fill in the squares
that we're allowed to move into
once it calculates all of these possible
moves let's have a quick look at this
code so okay so we're using a tuple here
so vector of tuples in in okay so
immediately i'm going to say i don't
like this i don't like to use tuples why
because they make no sense so this is
pretty obvious move type but int and end
i mean i can probably deduce this is
like the coordinate of where you're
moving
but
the thing is if you had used a struct
instead so for example you might have
had something like possible move as a
struct and then you can have like x
coordinate
y coordinate and
you know
piece
uh move type
you know move type or whatever
right this obviously makes more sense
because you just have one of these
it's clear what these actually are
because they have names performance wise
does not matter at all same thing right
it's just more kind of from the code
side to be a little bit better and then
when you use them see the problem is
you're using std get
so instead of doing that guess what we
would be doing we would be doing a value
dot
and then what we want so like x coord
instead of std get one which who on
earth knows what that means its value
dot y coord right so hopefully you can
see how much better and more clear this
code becomes now now it is also possible
to use structured bindings with tuples
so if you do actually really want to use
tuples and not make a struct out of it
which again i would i would make a
struct but what you can do is actually
use structured bindings which basically
just means that what we can do is stick
in some uh names for this here i don't
know why i got rid of const but uh you
know like x chord
by quart and uh move type we can
actually stick that in over here right
getting rid of this value of course and
then we just basically are expanding
these but also giving them names so this
just becomes
that right and then this becomes that so
at the very least you can do something
like this if you are using c plus 17 or
newer because that is a relatively new
feature but again i would just use
structs in which case everything's fine
even if you're using c plus
whatever c plus plus 1900 okay anyway
i'm gonna undo all of this so that we
can still compile the code without me
changing everything
um but other than that i don't really
have any problems with this uh you know
you're being a little bit inconsistent
with your um curly brackets here
you know if you're using if statements
and functions as
next line you should do the same for for
loops not a big deal obviously just
something i noticed uh set render and
draw color and then doing all of this
stuff so it's candle screen width
divided by eight again getting the
coordinate um
and or rather creating the rectangle uh
from the coordinates so we're taking the
chord again you see what i mean like
this is so hard to read like this is the
x coordinate std get zero
value that is the x coordinate this is
just terrible like don't
it would make much more sense if you had
x chord or something like that here or
at least x c even though that's a bit
cryptic maybe x coordinate you know just
x that would make much more sense so
that's kind of what i'm trying to
communicate here otherwise the function
doesn't really have a big issue so
you're getting the screen width dividing
it by 8 which gives us 80 and then we're
multiplying the coordinate bytes so
we're going back from the kind of
coordinate space which is what these two
values are into screen space or into
like pixel space so that we can actually
figure out what the bounds of this
physical rectangle is made out of pixels
should be
and then of course this is just going to
be um like a width and height of 80 by
80. so i'm interested in what like
because the remember the um the pieces
were blurry right so let's see what size
the pieces are let's see if i can find
them here so
we've got an image here i
can't open the files the png file man
okay so i found the pieces and it looks
like they are 60 by 60 and you're
rendering them as 80 by 80. so what i
would do is
just
find some high resolution
art right have some high resolution
pieces because otherwise it looks bad or
you can like reduce the resolution of
the game which is probably not good as
well i'm like crying from these
allergies so let's try and find uh where
was this
sdl like handler i think
yeah so if we make this like 480 by 480
is that right six times
66 60 times eight yep so if we rerun
that now
then yeah so that looks really crisp
okay so um
get some high resolution
images high resolution textures 60 by 60
pixels is tiny like what are you doing
get some high resolution
pictures okay so that's the render
possible moves i mean we didn't really
finish this function but it's pretty
simple all we're really doing is uh
rendering like filled rectangles here
and then we are rendering what's this
rendering
so this is going to
oh so it is going through the entire
board and rendering it again okay sure
so we are in fact re-rendering i guess
everything
uh we rendered this rectangle which
looks to be like the possible
move and then we go through
all of these and we render and fill
which is the piece so we render the
pieces on top i guess
sure say my name
say my name no peace here okay
um if handler is not pointing sure again
this is probably a good place to use
asserts instead of just this because
that would help you through development
instead of having to watch the console
like a hawk to see if something's gone
wrong you would get a nice kind of uh
like a break point basically appear here
that you could just use to debug the
current state of the application
otherwise yeah um and this is another
kind of see first second like you don't
want to be doing that like a pair
position of the piece make a struct
chord like point or something that just
has two integers in it x and y and use
that that way you can use x and y
instead of having to be all weird and
use
um you know first and second x and y
would make much more sense right so
structs are your friend okay so pulling
back into into the main kind of loop
here
um when we do mouse up it's going to
undo render possible moves okay
right so that's going to i guess render
the board but without the possible moves
that's a bit weird wouldn't you just
render like when you just render the
whole board normally because again this
looks like it's getting the possible
moves so what exactly happens when we do
mouse up ah this doesn't work because
yeah that's another thing right so all
of your logic all of your like you know
the mouse dragging code for example all
relies
on the cell being 80 by 80
which you know isn't a huge problem but
you should use a variable for this right
just like you used a variable for like
the width and height
of um
of the screen right so you can see
screen width and you know i mean eight
you can just keep using i guess because
it's not like that's going to change
probably unless you have some weird
variant of chess maybe with more kind of
um uh tiles or cells right but like i
don't like the divided by 80. so you
should probably have something like cell
width whoops
cell
width which will be like you know 80 uh
and that way you can easily change that
to 60 or even better you can just do
spring with divided by eight right
because you know that's going to be
that size so i would definitely make a
constant out of that
because otherwise you know if you do
change the resolution like this then
it's going to be an issue but
furthermore it's not going to work if
you actually make the window resizable
like i think you should okay so back to
blur town
if i drag this here then yeah it moves
this here but again i'm not sure why you
don't because you definitely like you
obviously have something that renders
the board so why
why would you not just why do you have
to undo
that kind of rendering i don't really
get it where even am i so undo render
possible moves because after this if
it's a valid move
oh well i guess maybe
let's just quickly see what happens here
maybe this doesn't happen when i think
it does no it does
so what if what happens if we comment it
out
okay right so the whole board doesn't
get refreshed
we missed this so it must not in fact be
the oh because it's the background i see
so you render all the pieces on top but
the background you basically never
render okay that makes sense um i'm not
sure if i i'd probably just re-render
the whole background to be honest and
not have to worry about undoing this but
i can see what you're doing now you're
you're replacing that kind of
uh like greenish turquoise color or
whatever with like white or with the
dark square whatever it should be for
the particular possible moves and then
you're rendering the pieces on top of
them so see this is another thing i
would do i would bring this out into a
function like render pieces
or something right um that will just go
through and do that that way you don't
have to duplicate the code multiple
times like you've got it here and then
you've got the exact same code here and
then i'm assuming maybe in some other
places as well
in general of course we try to
reduce code duplication as much as
possible so it's easier to maintain and
change code as time goes on because you
don't need to hunt it down everywhere
and see what it is okay so x um and
we've gone through that clicked on it so
if we've clicked on something if it's
not not null pointer
um then we figure that out again yeah
these states this can just be combined
right so you can just move this down
here it's not like xn does
needs to be calculated before that or
whatever that would just kind of
streamline this a little bit more if
clicked on get so if it's if it's the
same team you have a lot of if clicked
on get team equals get turn um like
literally you have this everywhere if
you see yourself kind of using this
multiple times i would definitely
like take it out
um you know is valid move or whatever
um i would definitely like take it out
and actually uh kind of
you know into a variable so you can use
it multiple times easily without having
to write that same code multiple times
but even better since you use it in
really a lot of a lot of places i would
probably bring it out into a function
called like is valid move for
team or i don't know is valid move and
just kind of use that instead because
that would just kind of save you from
you know checking to see if the current
team if it's the current teams go is
current is teams go or something like
that i don't know i mean what are you
checking game get turned and clicked on
get team right so is team's turn i guess
would be good
all right um
yeah and then what do we do so game is
valid move so how do we how do we
calculate these valid moves so peace get
possible moves okay so this is where we
actually are getting into
the hierarchy
of
our pieces so we have a base class
called peace
um and then that has like a particular
team that it's on it's got a piece type
uh so one thing i would do with these
enums is i would it looks like you have
a lot of these kind of like empty or
none you have these like zero states but
they're at the end of the list
uh what i would do is actually make them
first because this gives them the value
two
which doesn't make sense to me like i
think that none should be zero
uh and then you should go
up right like that right and same with
this like you should have empty as like
zero
a lot of times i actually explicitly
write zero just so that it's clear you
don't need to it will be zero anyway
unless you start it with some other
value like negative one or something
it's just kind of like equating i guess
uh
empty or none with false and because
false is also zero so that's why i like
to do that um and then you've got again
you know these possible moves which as i
mentioned should be potentially a struct
you're returning this by value which i
wouldn't do either because it's a member
variable here
i would mark this as const and then have
this be a const reference that way you
are not copying a vector and dynamically
allocating memory you want to kind of
avoid those memory allocations where
possible
uh and again you know this is like an
event driven game so realistically
you'll probably never see any
performance issues with stuff like this
but it's still good practice like for
the future
uh team get team sure set new position
uh okay again i wouldn't make that a pad
make it a struct we have a constructor
for all these pieces right so i'm
assuming you're calling this like
however many pieces there are what are
how many pieces are there i think like
six per team right like 12 different
paces i think so okay copy constructor
sure
copy constructor why do you have copy
constructor are you copying pieces for
um this should uh i would probably just
mark this as a default unless you're
doing because it doesn't look like
you're doing anything special
right and then in that case you can just
get rid of this because it looks like
you're literally just saying this i mean
i guess you're you're not copying the
texture though you're just setting the
texture now i'm not sure if that's an
error but for some reason you're not and
you're sending this to false so usually
usually unless you have a good reason
for this usually obviously copy
constructors would copy
um so maybe that is special i'm not sure
destructor rendered this piece prints
name of peace calculate possible move so
i'm interested in this okay so let's go
into like a let's go into something uh
basic like a pawn so what does that do
okay so in the pawns constructor we load
the file so i'm hoping you don't call
this eight times or rather 16 times
eight for each side um but we basically
uh load okay so pd pdt for
black so i guess dark and then light
light theme for um
for white we take in this handler so
this is kind of um this kind of uh
object-oriented design i'm not really a
big fan of either because you're you're
taking this handler which uh you looks
like you then don't use anywhere so i'm
not sure why you even need it in the
first place
but it's kind of creating this like uh
you know
it's almost like a circular kind of
dependency i mean it's not gonna cause
really any problems it's more of a
design issue right because
the handler should be kind of well then
again it's the sdl handler it's not like
you're taking in the game right i
actually kind of thought it was like the
game so you wouldn't want to take that
in because you don't necessarily want
the pieces to be aware of like the game
the game like the meta game and
everything the meta game should contain
the pieces and it should be the one
giving them instructions um but this is
a sdl handler which is specifically i
guess like the rendering stuff right uh
troll rectangle undo piece render load
image all right it needs it for loading
image up here which is again fine but i
wouldn't assign it to a member variable
because it i don't think you need it um
i mean other pieces i guess might use it
but pawn certainly doesn't seem to be
okay calculate possible moves so i guess
this will go through and actually figure
out like which moves are
valid so let's see how we do this so
it's checking like the current position
plus the delta and the delta is probably
right mdy direction the pawn moves oh
okay so this is not like
uh okay i see this is like a fixed kind
of delta so this is just immediately a
quick check to see
um whether or not like we are actually
within the bounds of the board because
zero is like the first tile and seven is
the max tile so this is actually an
interesting check because this is the
thing that will promote us uh that's one
thing we didn't check actually right
because i guess the idea is if that plus
d y is in fact a zero then we've reached
the end of the board and we should get a
queen that's one other thing i didn't
check let me check that quickly okay so
let's try and uh
get
rid of
this
we'll just uh step aside
and let this oh let's check
and let this uh win
oh look at this this is a pleasant
surprise
nice
yeah that's pretty cool
okay so that works as well which is nice
so this is just again calculating the
possible moves but i guess the move type
here obviously becomes a new piece move
because that's a promotion for the pawn
um so that's a quick little check but
again like it's only possible to do if
there's nothing in the way here right so
this is us checking to see this next
position that we've checked is in fact
the promotion kind of the base uh rank
kind of position so that's kind of an
easy uh i guess well this is these are
pawns in general so they're kind of easy
this is just a normal move i guess if
we're
um if that's not the case again we're
just checking to see if it's uh if it's
empty or not uh but then i guess this is
where it gets interesting one thing i
want to mention about this code so far
is that it would have really benefited
from some annotating right you used
comments a lot before
in places that maybe
are like a little bit meaningless but
then over here
you know where like check for promotion
or whatever you don't have anything like
this so you really need to you really
should use comments more like this right
because this code is a little bit it
takes it takes a second to understand so
this is like the whole has moved thing
which i'm assuming uh
well actually
looks like see this is public so it's
some
it's hard to check but i'm assuming the
house move thing is the thing that gives
you the two kind of the ability to move
two squares forward if you want on your
first move anyway i'm not gonna spend
time doing all this here's a little on
poisson kind of
uh
uh
section here which again is a little
weird because uh like this has a bull in
it so if true ampersand is possible in
the inter direction so again this is set
by kind of external forces
which um
you know makes it a little bit harder to
kind of sort through but i guess that's
probably necessary because it's not
really up to you whether or not you can
do that so you can see over here inside
the game if there's just uh i guess some
kind of pawn move that's happened then
we can set that to true in negative one
direction anyway like a lot of chess is
obviously just really specific rules and
i don't think that i need to kind of go
through all of this and explain
or try and explain to you how it's
implemented
it's all pretty like standard it's all
pretty much done by hand right just kind
of filling in valid moves like if we
look at the knight for example you can
see that we basically check for a grid
like grid kind of adjacent squares in a
grid around it right so that we can kind
of just see if there are um empty
squares there or i guess squares with
the opponent's pieces that we can
actually move into there's kind of two
rounds of this as well one which focuses
on like the x and the y because this
only iterates through the for loop a
total of like four times i think and
this does another four but in the other
directions then we get impossible moves
here so this doesn't actually return
them it just calculates them and then we
get the possible moves here and then we
can retrieve them uh by calling like get
possible moves or something up here this
kind of code is always tedious to do
um i can see that you've done it like
using for loops which is fine um
i probably wouldn't have done it this
way just because if you take a look at
these for loops they're pretty useless
in the sense that what they're doing is
they're checking two states you're
basically checking d y is minus two and
then d y is two because you're adding
four right so this is checking minus two
and positive two
and then this is checking minus one and
positive one so what i would do instead
is i would actually create some kind of
like array
of certain moves again i would use like
a x y point class so let me just uh
you know break this down here
so we have x y we have an array of
points and these are the possible
squares or whatever right and you would
need to obviously check this with the
bounds of the board as well but you
could do something like this and then
you can just define these things
right so
i'm not sure so i guess in this case we
would have four but then this also has
four right so in total the knight has
eight kind of squares that it can move
to so maybe i would do something like
this and then you can just list them
here minus two two
two
two
i mean this was for the y but i think
you kind of get the point minus two two
and then for the y again for the y we're
supposed to have minus one and one so we
can do minus one one and then we
duplicate this and then this time we can
have something like that right and
that's four of the possible moves and
then all you have to do is kind of
iterate through that so possible squares
and then let's just pretend we did
actually have four let's just add that
there um and then let's just go through
all of these
moves possible squares
and then that's kind of
that's your for loop done right and then
you can combine them and just do them
all in one because it looks i mean
looking at this code the way that you're
calculating this like it's all
identical right lots of code duplication
there as well so listing something like
this out would be helpful and then if
you were really cool with your comments
what you could also do is attempt to
actually draw out a board that would
explain like what these points are so
this is just me being extra cool here
but you could basically say that like
the knight originates here and then what
we're doing we're going minus two and
then minus one so we can move here
and then same but like plus one right
and then
same but positive two right so this kind
of fills in these moves that the knight
can make but then also you would have
like the other four that i mentioned we
would also need to implement which are
these four right and then this kind of
is a nice nice visualization of what in
fact we're doing here and if you were
even cooler you could actually label
these so that you could easily kind of
validate them and i mean i don't know
like none of this is not this is
necessary but it might be kind of cool
to just look at
you know
kind of visualize what you're actually
doing i don't know maybe i should make
like a little chess game in hazel or
something that'd actually be a cool
project for the game engine series kind
of hazel 2d but anyway uh that's pretty
much all of the code um again all these
move things
you know textures rendering uh this just
draws a rectangle with that texture
again that's where that kind of
distortion is happening because you have
the 60 by 60 texture then you're drawing
it to a destination rectangle that is
640 divided by 8 which is 80. right so
you're just kind of stretching it out a
little bit you're getting all that
blurriness um but other than that i
think you've done a pretty decent job at
everything the code is relatively clean
uh there's a lot of again use of like
heap allocated objects where they don't
just they just don't need to be right i
would like to see a bit more you know
stack allocated stuff again you don't
really need unique pointer here that was
just an example i would make it like
that probably
um and then wait actually where do you
make all of the pieces i haven't really
seen that part yet have i while i'm
looking uh for that i also noticed this
so calculated possible moves again takes
in piece pointers and then an eight by
eight two dimensional array of them so
this is kind of confusing i probably
wouldn't do that i'd have like uh
probably like an scd array of like 64 of
these i like one dimensional arrays more
just because they're less kind of
indirect when you're dealing with them
uh but you know this might be easier i
guess um but again you know if you're
dealing with one-dimensional versus
two-dimensional arrays it's still
there's an easy kind of way to convert
that right you just do like x plus y
times width so it's it's super simple um
but anyway let's let's try and find
those pieces being created so over here
in init is where you uh create all the
sdl stuff again looks pretty simple and
here it is the game class okay so yeah
this is like a lot of stuff i mean you
could have you could have definitely
used some for loops here um because you
know you're creating identical pawns for
example here i mean obviously for some
things you can't use for loops but i
would do that this is also once you've
created the pieces i'm glad that you
kind of store the pieces somewhat
permanently so you're not like
recreating them all the time that's nice
not that it's a bad thing to recreate
them but again if they're heap allocated
objects like that as well as long as
they're like fixed i guess it's not too
bad if you're doing that in
initialization but yeah um
you know going through all these then
manually assigning them to like all the
different cells a little bit tedious a
little bit annoying but
more or less um oh actually wait okay so
you're creating individual pawns
yeah so
this is again like a situation where you
know we don't need eight pawns for each
side right we really just need one pawn
and then we need to like
render it many times and also keep track
of eight instances of it but we don't
actually need eight pawns so if i was to
do this i'd do it a bit differently
especially because every time you create
a pawn
each every time you create
eight of these white pawns you're
loading the image repeatedly and you're
storing like a reference of it here
right that's completely unnecessary as
well they all look the same you should
kind of take eight instances of them
um you know when you're rendering we'll
actually have one instance of it and
then just render it eight times for
example but then obviously you need to
have some kind of lightweight kind of
piece object or something that is just
like you know this is the piece this is
like what team it belongs to this is its
coordinates
and then uh well that's it right the the
type of the piece and then then that's
it that's all you need so i definitely
wouldn't wouldn't set it up like this
uh and then you calculate all moves this
so i guess these are like the starting
moves
or something wow but then yeah you're
going through okay so this is all of the
moves possible for the current pieces on
the board okay so you kind of do that
like up front i guess but yeah that's uh
that's pretty much it hope you guys
enjoyed this code review if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button below don't forget that you can
send in your code to china review
gmail.com there will be like some
instructions in the description below so
definitely check that out i never know
what i'm gonna like review until i just
open up that email address and i just
get you know all these messages there
and then i just pick so it's always a
blast always a fun time and never really
know what's coming next if you guys also
have some like opinions about this code
definitely share them in the comments
section below but other than that thank
you guys for watching don't forget to
check out skillshare using the link in
the description below and i will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you